[Music]
we're in the oprah slash diane sawyer
you know barbara walters
wolf
octavia yes thank you for joining
us today
[Music]
so here we are
you know what i was thinking about was
how excited i am to actually promote the
show yes
because it's been so much fun for us to
work together working with you is one of
the most amazing gifts
oh you know uh oh my god i mean i have
separation anxiety i know i'm like
others are crying right now
hey let me just tell you honey with how
crazy tv schedules are
you got to be able to count on your
scene partners and you're you're more
than gifted actress that we know
you just have this disarming calm
whenever we get the scene up on its feet
after you leave it's like oh wait is it
just me by myself
no there's no fun there we're real seed
partners it's true
in the show it's a complicated
relationship poppy and micah were
friends from when we were kids
we haven't seen each other a bit and
then
boom we find my husband murdered
these women love each other so much and
there's so much we're hiding and we're
constantly forcing each other to open up
i loved the first season but i feel like
we really went there with this season it
feels really personal
poppy i need you to help me find out
what happened to joshua seeking answers
is never a straight line
what's your favorite part about this
season my favorite part about this
season is through micah and poppy's
relationship poppy has to deal with her
demons to solve josh's murder and i love
that it's also from the perspective of
this lifelong friendship
i want to have
the the gravitas of this character
but also have some of the humor and the
fun that we got to play yeah
why did you want to play micah why did i
want to do this show first of all was
really because of you oh
before i even really knew what it was i
was like this is going to be really fun
i thought what a great world to enter
into
i think the thing is it's so fun about
doing something like this is that
there's intensity in terms of character
dynamic and serious story lines but at
the end of the day this is a whodunit
yeah and who's doing it and who did it
there's something just juicy and fun
about it
[Music]
you're gonna try to figure out who did
it like on episode one and that's
exciting for me
[Music]
it's constantly keeping you guessing
guessing and i love that me
[Music]
too good
it was a love fest that was a love fest
and it was effortless
that is a two thumbs up for me
you